- [Instructor] We are asked, what could
be the equation of p?
And we have graph of our
polynomial p right over here,
you could view this as the graph
of y is equal to p of x.
So pause this video and see
if you can figure that out.
All right, now let's
work on this together,
and you can see that all
the choices have p of x,
in factored form where it's very easy
to identify the zeros or the x values
that would make our
polynomial equal to zero.
And we could also look at this graph
and we can see what the zeros are.
This is where we're going
to intersect the x-axis,
also known as the x-intercepts.
So you can see when x is
equal to negative four,
we have a zero because our
polynomial is zero there.
So we know p of negative
four is equal to zero.
We also know that p of, looks like 1 1/2,
or I could say 3/2.
p of 3/2 is equal to zero,
and we also know that p
of three is equal to zero.
So let's look for an
expression where that is true.
And because it's in factored form,
each of the parts of the product
will probably make our polynomial zero
for one of these zeroes.
So let's see if, if in
order for our polynomial
to be equal to zero when x
is equal to negative four,
we probably want to have a term
that has an x plus four in it.
Or we want to have a, I should say,
a product that has an x plus four in it.
Because x plus four is equal
to zero when x is equal to negative four.
Well we have an x plus four there,
and we have an x plus four there.
So I'm liking choices B and D so far.
Now for this second root, we have p of 3/2
is equal to zero so I would look
for something like x
minus 3/2 in our product.
I don't see an x minus 3/2 here,
but as we've mentioned in other videos
you can also multiply
these times constants.
So if I were to multiply,
let's see to get rid
of this fraction here,
if I multiply by two this
would be the same thing as,
let me scroll down a little bit,
same thing as two x minus three.
And you could test that out,
two x minus three is equal to
zero when x is equal to 3/2.
And let's see, we have a two x
minus three right over there.
So choice D is looking awfully good,
but let's just verify
it with this last one.
For p of three to be equal to zero,
we could have an expression
like x minus three in the product
because this is equal to zero
when x is equal to three,
and we indeed have that right over there.
So choice D is looking very good.
When x is equal to negative four,
this part of our product is equal
to zero which makes the
whole thing equal to zero.
When x is equal to 3/2,
two x minus three is equal
to zero which makes the
entire product equal to zero.
And when x minus, and when
an x is equal to three,
it makes x minus three equal to zero.
Zero times something, times something
is going to be equal to zero.